The dollies.
Zoom is one of the most disorienting and
flashy camera techniques of all time
and it shows up in some of the most
beloved scenes in cinematic history.
It's famous for,
it's bizarre look,
but the shot also teaches us a lot about
filmmaking.
It shows the different kinds of lenses
and how to use them.
It enhances the emotion of the scene and
it can be used in subtle places.
You may not have even noticed.
Let's see how
the dollies zoom or sometimes called the
vertical effect started in hitchcock's
film vertigo in 1958 you need a smooth
track and steady zoom to pull it off
nicely,
which is why it wasn't developed sooner.
The shot is essentially an optical
illusion because by zooming in or out on
the camera lens while tracking the
camera forward or backward,
the result is the foreground stays in
the same position.
While the background appears to squeeze
or stretch,
depending on which direction you go,
it actually teaches an important
principle of filming camera Lens.
If you ever wanted to see the difference
between wide angle and telephoto lenses.
A simplified example would be to observe
at.compare how it begins to how it ends.
The dollies soon shot can start like a
telephoto lens for the camera is far
away and the focal length is bigger.
There's less background insight because
the lens concentrates on a smaller
portion of,
but when you change focal lens by
zooming out while also pushing the
camera forward,
you can observe more of the background
while keeping the foreground in the same
place.
The result is filming the same thing,
but the camera expands to see more of
the background.
The change in focal length takes in a
wider area,
so you go from a telephoto shot to a
wide angle shot.
You generally use telephoto and closeups
to keep attention on the foreground when
you move the camera around while using a
telephoto Lens,
the background whips quickly behind the
foreground because the camera takes in
less of the background.
It makes for some pretty cool shots.
People also tend to look better and
telephoto because their faces aren't
stressed by the wider Lens.
Wide Angle takes in more of the
background,
so it's better for outdoor shots.
When you want to capture the landscape,
so each lens is a tradeoff,
the dollies and captures the transition
from one kind of lens shot to the other
and it leads to different emotional
responses for the viewer.
Vertigo uses the dollies zoom to give a
sense of height.
This increase in height perfectly
embodies how the telephoto has a more
narrow view of the background,
so we'd go from capturing a lot of the
background to capturing very little.
The results is a dizzying optical
illusion.
The shot is unsettling,
even a little bit nauseating for some
because it's physically impossible to
experience without some kind of lens
alteration.
In goodfellas,
the diner scene becomes all the more
confusing as the landscape shifts around
them and impossible ways.
Just as Henry's world is crushing and
his paranoia grows,
the impossible movement of the diner
shows just how disoriented he feels.
The zoom makes the world literally close
in around him as getting caught seems
almost inevitable.
As I mentioned before,
the Wide Angle Lens makes people look a
bit off with the famous Dolly's zoom in
jaws,
the shot shifts to a wide angle look,
which makes his face look just a bit
more stretched and unnatural,
and it unconsciously adds to the rest of
the freakiness of the shock.
Those three examples,
vertigo,
jaws and Goodfellas,
or the Goto examples,
whenever anybody mentions the dollies
zoom,
the promise that when teaching the shot,
the examples usually stop there,
which is a shame because it makes a shot
seem like a one off effect for legendary
movies,
but it's actually a lot more versatile
and common than that.
It's out of this world.
Visual look makes it commonly used for
the supernatural or the feeling of a
drug trip.
I particularly enjoy.
It's used in the Lord of the rings
because the widening of the holes in the
trees gives the visual feeling that the
forest is opening up a portal for the
enemy to come.
It's almost always used out of movies,
climactic ethic moment,
so if you're a hero fails,
it adds to the punchline.
The shot has even found its way into
animation.
Bradford uses it extensively in his
films.
The food critic flashback gets enhanced
with a dollar zoom effect to simulate
the transportation from one world to
another.
Animation,
particularly computer generated,
has a distinct opportunity to use the
photo in interesting ways because of
animations,
complete control of object placement.
As remy relates to chef Gusteau,
the dollies whom is no longer used to
disorient the viewer,
but to show them,
get physically closer together,
indicating a relationship is born.
The incredibles has a seemingly
impossible Dolly's.
Soon as Mrs incredible gets closer to
the temptation.
Both instances are non disruptive,
but also draw our attention to certain
parts of the shot with its trademark
squeezing effect.
The Delis,
whom is certainly a fantastical shot at
the disposal of the filmmaker.
But remember,
it's more than just a cheap trick.
Alfred Hitchcock use different depths or
says he used it to show paranoia,
and Brad Bird used it for visual cues.
So be on the lookout for it.
Thanks for watching.
[inaudible].
What are you staring at fucker?